[Musique]
Hélène buzetti Jonathan Trudeau allait
castonguet bonsoir
je le disais en début d'émission le PLQ
est à son plus bas mais c'est avec
auteur que la quitté je trouve ce matin
un discours assez digne première
question que je vous pose est-ce que
Madame anglaise avait vraiment le choix
de quitter ou de rester Hélène
écoutez je pense que quand ce genre de
spirale s'emballe ça devient presque
inéluctable que le chef doit quitter on
l'a vu avec anducheur
et par spirale j'entends par là bon les
libéraux qui ont montré les dents il
n'aime pas la défaite ils l'ont bien
fait sentir les journalistes aussi qui
ont quand même été très acharnés il y a
eu un peu à mon avis un peu de
d'acharnement médiatique a toujours
répéter cette histoire elle finit par se
concrétiser et donc dans le contexte je
pense qu'elle n'avait plus le choix
c'était inévitable ceci dit je dirais
quand même que il y a l'aspect pandémie
aussi qui a sûrement joué elle a été
élue chef alors que la pandémie battait
son plein et je fais la comparaison avec
d'autres chefs politiques qui ont eux
aussi été sélectionnés pendant la
pandémie everno tool ou Steven Deluca le
chef libéral en Ontario qui tousse deux
aussi ont eu de la difficulté à se faire
connaître tous deux ont été défaits face
à des premiers ministres sortants et ils
sont partis eux aussi Jonathan même
question avait-elle le choix
non je pense qu'il avait absolument pas
le choix en fait elle aurait pu
s'accrocher et risquer une défaite
humiliante lors d'un éventuel vote de
confiance je crois que c'est ce qui est
le mesurer au cours des derniers jours
c'est-à-dire l'impossibilité de de
remonter suffisamment dans les
prochaines semaines prochain mois
évidemment le certain diront avec avec
justesse que c'est pas c'est pas
toujours juste la politique et Madame
Anglade qui a jamais eu vraiment
l'occasion d'assoir si on veut sa
légitimité son leadership au sein du
parti Béral du Québec d'être pleinement
la chef du Parti Bel-Air du Québec et il
y a pas aucune raison à ça mais je pense
que on peut principalement regarder le
fait que elle a été couronnée il y a pas
eu de course à la chefferie ce qui je
pense lui enlever lui enlever un peu de
fermeté de légitimité comme chef du
parti du Québec et suite à ça il y a eu
une succession d'autres mauvaises
discussions il y a pas seulement les
astres qui étaient mal alignés madame
Morgane on lui a souvent reproché de ne
pas bien s'entourer des mauvaises
décisions donc au niveau de
l'organisation évidemment toujours été
le coup fatal c'est cette décision
catastrophique d'expulser la députée
Marie-Claude Nicole je pense que ça agit
comme un accélération jeu par rapport au
sort de Madame Anglet c'est clair afin
de la libérer la parole les gens comme
dit hélène se les journalistes
cherchaient même pas les gens se
précipitaient pour pour parler allez
qu'en pensez-vous
pour pouvoir rester plus longtemps en
poste qui aurait fallu que Dominique
Anglade soit capable de plaider quel
était ou qu'elle a des arguments à faire
valoir ils sont problèmes c'est qu'il
n'y avait les résultats électoraux pour
plaider de rester un peu plus longtemps
elle n'avait pas réussi à organiser
suffisamment son parti sur le terrain
pour avoir même des associations locales
dans chacune des circonscriptions et
venez une énorme désorganisation chez
ces militants au point où on n'a pas été
capable de trouver des candidats de
qualité dans beaucoup de
circonscriptions aux dernières élections
la plateforme électorale n'était pas à
la hauteur elle n'a pas été capable
d'expliquer l'hydrogène vert qu'est-ce
que ça mangeait en hiver pourquoi c'est
important on a fait des erreurs dans le
cadre financier tout ça c'est quand même
la chef à un moment ou un autre qui est
responsable des déboires de son parti
donc si elle avait bien performé en
campagne électorale avec un parti à la
hauteur des attentes et que les gens
n'en veulent pas c'est une chose la
performance a pas été bonne les gens
n'en voulaient pas donc comment on fait
pour faire patienter les militants les
candidats déçus les exécutés il y avait
pas beaucoup de choses dans
l'argumentaire de devenir candidate pour
dire on va se rendre jusqu'à un congrès
mais pourquoi qu'allez-vous offrir de
plus et c'est cet argumentaire là
qu'elle n'avait plus un moment donné si
on n'est pas capable de faire patienter
ses propres troupes au mieux elle a
hérité d'un parti amoché c'est le moins
que l'on puisse dire par beaucoup
d'histoires par un passé dans quelle
mesure elle est responsable dans quel
quel est le pourcentage de
responsabilité qu'elle doit porter sur
les malheurs du pelq avoir je vous la
fais écouter et elle lance un petit
avertissement à ceux qui restent de quoi
on écoute
les enjeux démographiques culturels
socio-économiques et écologiques sont
trop importants pour que l'opposition
officielle soit déchirée
le Parti libéral du Québec doit opérer
un renouvellement de son offre politique
mais aussi de sa façon de faire de la
politique
et on n'a pas le luxe d'être mini par
des intrigues internes dont les
Québécois n'ont que faire
jusqu'à notre mort la mienne avant la
vôtre on va entendre cette expression là
faire de la politique autrement c'est
pas trop exactement qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire qu'est-ce que vous décoder
dans ce que le dit Jonathan
il y a peut-être un aveu aussi la danse
c'est-à-dire que Dominique Anglade elle
n'a pas été capable si on veut de
rebâtir l'identité du Parti vert du
Québec je pense que au-delà de l'usure
du pouvoir et l'espèce de négation là
qui est toujours ambiante au parti
Belgrade du Québec le c'est-à-dire que
on doit accepter que le parti badge du
Québec en ce moment n'est plus imparti
le naturel de de gouvernance qu'il doit
y avoir une longue traversée du désert
une remise en question au-delà de ça on
a on ne savait plus quel était
l'identité de ce parti est-ce que c'est
un parti qui voulait aller davantage à
sa gauche pour pouvoir rivaliser avec
Québec solidaire avec le Parti québécois
est-ce qu'il voulait plus incarner
certains nationalistes comme l'acaque le
faisait également j'ai l'impression que
le parti se cherche pour parler très
régulièrement avec plusieurs militants
militants encore actif mais aussi des
anciens des gens disaient tout
simplement on ne reconnaît plus le Parti
libéral du Québec sous Dominique anglais
alors imaginez quand vos propres
militants votre base traditionnelle ne
se reconnaît plus comment vous pouvez
penser espérer aller rejoindre un plus
large directeur là c'était chose ces
choses impossible pour Madame anglaise
dans la mesure actuelle
quand la CAQ a pris une partie de ce qui
faisait la force partie libérale
c'est-à-dire l'économie etc quand on lit
ça en tête déboussolé Hélène oui j'ai
quand même vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure que ça sortit était très digne
et elle était effectivement très
difficile de faire ce qu'elle a fait
encore quoi un mois en entrevue avec
vous Patrice elle dit oui je vais rester
et là il faut qu'on parte la dans les
gens
par contre du diagnostic qu'elle a posé
quand elle parle de la division bon ok
il y a eu de la division dans les
derniers jours mais parce que les gens
voulaient qu'elle participe pas comme si
dans la dernière année on a vu un
étalage des divisions libérales partout
et surtout quand elle se dit il faut que
le Parti libéral prenne résolument je
sais pas exactement les mots mais parler
de l'égalité des femmes parler de la
question climatique comme quoi elle est
importante je suis désolé mais je ne
pense pas que les Québécois ont tourné
le dos au parti libérale du Québec parce
qu'ils estiment qu'elle parle pas assez
de l'égalité homme-femme qu'il parle pas
assez d'environnement je pense encore et
toujours que c'est beaucoup une question
sur la question
identitaire cette incapacité viscérale
qu'on les libéraux provinciaux de
connecter avec ce mal être identitaire
québécois
l'approche chartiste finalement du PLQ
qui pensera toujours que les droits
individuel doivent primer surtout désirs
collectif de préserver une quelconque
identité je pense que c'est ça qui est à
l'origine du Parti libéral et on
n'entend pas encore personne
justement là-dessus c'est intéressant
Jonathan et elle est mais en même temps
si elle veut aller plus si elle a voulu
emmener à aller plus vers ce cours pour
répondre aux demandes du courant plus
national nationalistes
identitaire mais là les d'autres
militants on dit mais qu'est-ce que vous
faites c'est ça qui est difficile
Jonathan de réconcilier là
ouais mais c'est parce que la difficulté
c'est de faire avoir de position assumer
c'est que Madame anglaise sur des enjeux
comme c'est trop souvent à cheval sur la
clôture mettait un pied d'un côté
finalement retourné retourné de l'autre
donc à vouloir plaire à peu près tout le
monde on finit par déplaire à une
majorité donc je pense qu'il y avait cet
aspect-là qui était qui était difficile
aussi pour Madame alex je vous donne la
parole mais je vous montre un tweet de
Eric Duhem tant qu'il résume bien
monsieur assez clair un tweet moins de
mots le Parti libéral du Québec n'est
plus longue de ce qu'il a été écrit-il
Dominique Anglade a fait ce qu'elle a pu
avec le parti qu'elle avait elle n'est
pas l'unique et ni grande responsable de
la chute des libéraux qu'en pensez-vous
à
oui je pense qu'il a raison soyons
honnêtes là la coalition à venir à
Québec a fait subir une très mauvaise
soirée à tous les partis politiques de 3
octobre donc AQs on espérait être
capable de faire des gains on en a
obtenu un particulier quoi on pensait
avoir une super campagne on a fini avec
3 députés 15 %. ça a été dur pour les
libéraux aussi donc c'est cette
parenthèse actuelle on sort de la
pandémie un événement historique
François LEGO a pris beaucoup de place
les gens apprécié en grande majorité sa
gestion de la pandémie on voulait le
récompenser le Parti libéral par contre
aurait probablement pu jouer la partie à
plus long terme comment ça se
positionner en Zaba 4 ans la situation
va être différente sur quoi on va être
les champions lequel il notre identité
Jonathan raison on est tout perdu au
parti libérales à la boussole est
complètement déréglée sur l'aspect
identitaire sur l'aspect économique sur
l'aspect fédéralisme donc au lieu de se
camper puis dire on va s'assumer on va
assumer une défaite aussi qui va aller
avec mon voisin s'assumer puis on va
dans 4 ans et positionner différemment
on a essayé de jouer encore à court
terme le parti qui était apte à
remplacer la coalition à venir Québec ça
pouvait pas être ça ça pouvait pas être
ça il y avait pas de place pour ça mais
les militants acceptent mal qu'on
construisent pour dans 4 ans ou dans 8
ans et ça fait en sorte qu'on a eu l'air
à chercher le bon filon à court terme
puis on a pas trouvé ça explique en
partie pourquoi on est aussi désorienté
voilà alors la question que les gens se
posent qui
mais accessoirement mais qui surtout
léger toujours très vite sur la gâchette
Journal de Montréal les gens a sorti cet
après-midi un premier sondage de
nicodère 9% Marwa risky 5 thermorosophie
Brochu sophie Brochu beaucoup de gens je
les dis plutôt chaque fois qu'elle vient
sur un plateau les gens nous écrivent
montrer elles devraient être chef Pierre
Arcan qui est en basket François
Philippe champagne je vois lightbarn
André Fortin bon
vous avez le choix des noms qui vous
inspirent il y a beaucoup de gens qui
ont déjà dit non
je n'ai pas de boule de cristal alors je
ne sais pas qui va y aller mais quand
même à la dernière fois j'ai pas
Jonathan disait tout à l'heure il y a eu
personne qui s'est opposé à Madame
Anglade bon monsieur qui sont pendant
quelques temps il fait des idées il ne
veut pas se relancer cette fois-ci
c'est que le Parti libéral est pas très
attrayant ces jours-ci quand vous
regardez du côté ici d'Ottawa dire
est-ce que des gens ici Ottawa qui
auraient le goût d'aller là vraiment
quand vous avez la possibilité d'être
ministre fédéral ou en tout cas être au
gouvernement fédéral retourner à Québec
pour diriger une opposition officielle
qui a pas de perspective de former le
gouvernement avant minimalement quatre
ans peut-être 8 c'est difficile à
convaincre les gens parlent sophie
Brochu je suis juste allé faire une
petite vérification ne dicte pas tout là
mais en tant que PDG de l'Hydro-Québec
elle fait 615000 dollars par année
chef de l'opposition officielle c'est
moins de 200
mais aussi j'ajouterai juste ce que je
trouve talent dans la décision de Madame
Anglade lorsqu'il décide de partir
maintenant ce qui va précipiter une
élection partielle qui coûte en passant
selon les derniers chiffres que j'ai
reçu le 585000 dollars en moyenne à
tenir n'aurait-elle pas pu attendre ne
serait-ce que pour permettre
éventuellement si le nouveau chef n'est
pas un élu de se présenter dans sa
circonscription là on risque de d'avoir
un phénomène en cascade peut-être de
d'avoir plusieurs élections partielles
pour la remplacer elle puis un jour
peut-être pour faire entrer le futur
chef oui mais vous avez dit vous-même
Hélène et Jonathan alex je vous donne la
parole que c'était comme un cercle
vicieux quand ça commençait on n'arrive
pas à arrêter cette machine là
aurait-elle pu rester le temps de mettre
les choses en ordre je suis pas sûr mais
Jonathan sur ça mais sur les députés
comme député
le sondage privilégier qu'on a vu il y a
quelques instants vous savez quoi j'ai
envie de vous dire que c'est la seule
bonne nouvelle pour le Parti libéral du
Québec aujourd'hui pourquoi parce que
c'est un parti qui ne peut pas faire
l'économie d'une vraie course à
l'échelle free d'un vrai débat de
prendre le temps de le faire de bien le
faire ne serait-ce que pour regarder les
coffres du parti ils en ont bien besoin
donc nous avons des candidats qui vont
vendre des cartes de membership donc un
couronnement là un candidat qui se
démarquerait au jour 1 qui serait une
évidence et ce serait pas rendre service
au parti Belgrade du Québec pour les
amateurs de sport là c'est comme qu'on
espère que le Canadien se refasse après
une échange d'aller chercher le joueur
qui m'a sauvé l'équipe ben non des fois
ça prenne reconstruction faut rebâtir
avec des jeunes joueurs donc moi je
pense que c'est une une bonne chose il y
a des noms là-dedans qui sont un peu des
automatismes c'est de voir encore Pierre
Moreau un nom qui revient dans
l'actualité je suis pas certain malgré
toutes ces qualités qu'il incarnent
exactement le renouveau qui recherchait
au Parti libéral du Québec sophie Brochu
c'est un espèce de de vœux que tous les
partis politiques feraient mais madame
jamais dans sa vie ne démontrer le
moindre intérêt pour se lancer en
politique donc ça n'arrivera pas Marwa
riski joue l'occasion de lui parler dans
les dernières heures elle vient tout
juste d'accoucher elle n'est absolument
pas là j'ai envie de vous dire que la
première question la première chose qui
doit se passer dans les prochaines
heures il doit y avoir une conversation
téléphonique entre Marc Tanguay et André
Fortin qui sont les deux prétendants
pour la chefferie intérimaire donc l'un
doit dire à l'autre et s'intéresser par
la chefferie tout court voir ce que
l'autre le champ libre pour la chef
interimaire moi je pense j'avais un
petit dodo dollar à Paris que c'est
peut-être ça qui va nous donner une
bonne indication moi je serais pas
surpris que Mark Tanguay soit tout
désigné pour la chiffrer intérimaire et
là faudra voir si André Fortin cette
fois-ci va se laisser
ou pas parce qu'on disait à l'époque oui
très bien
la mise à part de nicodère tout le monde
est dans la marge d'erreur dans ce
sondage c'est pas une très bonne
nouvelle pour personne qui voudraient se
lancer ça va aussi dire comme j'ai
entendu que la course est ouverte et ça
ça pourrait être intéressant pour des
candidats qui sont peut-être moins
connus du public mais qui aurait le
temps ne se fait connaître joël
lightband est un nom très intéressant
dans cette liste là Alain Reyes n'est
pas dans cette liste là moi je le
mettrai dans cette liste là
qui pourrait pourquoi pas
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus progressiste
conservateur que conservateur
parce que ça fait pas son affaire à
Ottawa la direction très populiste du
Parti conservateur très
environnementaliste Victoriaville est
devenu un référence en développement
durable lorsqu'il était maire de
Victoriaville en tout cas je vous dis
pas que ça étendre je ne lui ai pas
parlé vous dit que il y a des gens qui
pourraient bénéficier d'une course un
peu plus longue d'être un peu moins
connu plutôt que d'avoir une cour un
couple une vraie course est donc la
beauté des idées elle a la rencontre des
militants ça pourrait être intéressant
un mot avant de se sur ce qui se passe
avant couvert négociation on a vu
d'autres fois ces négociations Hélène le
monsieur Trudeau vient dire ici on va
pas mettre trop d'argent dans un système
brisé on veut des conditions comment
vous lisez ce qui est en train d'arriver
au cours des prochaines ce qui va
arriver et là ce soir il y a quand même
eu un développement le ministre de la
Santé fédéral monsieur Duclos a dit pour
la première fois qu'il était tout vert à
augmenter le transfert aux provinces
c'est-à-dire un c'est un montant qui est
envoyé sans condition en théorie quoique
dans sa déclaration on le dit je ferai
ça si vous donnez plus de d'informations
si vous produisez plus de statistiques
et là j'écoutais les ministres
provinciaux qui réagissaient on fait
déjà ça et ce n'est pas à Ottawa qu'on
doit des comptes ce sont à nos électeurs
alors mais bon ils sont quand même
contents de voir cette ouverture qui est
nouvelle et autrement ils veulent faire
Ottawa veut faire des ententes
asymétrique avec chaque province pour
voir quels sont leurs besoins et
témoigner de l'argent mais évidemment ça
veut encore dire kotawa va dicter votre
exiger l'addition du compte des
provinces conclusion Jonathan Alec très
rapidement
conclusion demain vous pensez Jonathan
régler demain j'entendais le ministre du
B qui déjà réagit donc à la proposition
de Jean-Yves Duclos en disant que
c'était
inacceptable de vouloir avoir une
certaine réédition de compte on voit que
le fédéral tente de briser le front un
nid avec les ententes asymétriques donc
je m'attends pas de grandes nouvelles de
mon ressortir de cette conférence là
Alec ça va pas se régler entre les
ministres de la santé ça va se régler
avec les ministres des Finances et
peut-être même Premier ministre
directement moi je ne pense pas qu'à
court terme on est capable de régler ça
on va mettre on coule la Fondation pour
une négociation qui va prendre plusieurs
semaines je pense
très bien Hélène Jonathan Alec merci
beaucoup bon début de semaine à très
bientôt au revoir pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI